well it's Wednesday and time for our pet
of the week segment and look who's here
John Barnes with the animal foundation
hi John and who is this handsome man
you've got with you this great dog is
Kobe hey Kobe four years old 80 pounds
still has a lot of energy in him he's a
big boy really great dog yeah you know
what he's our longest resident how long
has he been there 167 days why he seems
like such a great I know hi buddy what
do you think it is I think it's just
because he's big yeah 80 pounds he's a
lot and easy he loves to play he's been
playing with us ever since he came in
this morning now you say he's good with
other dogs he's good with other dogs
he's in our Ace Program which is our
Academy of canine etiquette okay so he's
learning manners yeah and he knows how
to fetch and give you his paw and all
that stuff okay
um he's great in our play groups we have
play groups other dogs play with him
right he likes females a little bit more
than males but he's very good with dogs
good how about cats he's not a cat
person oh he's not a cat person or
cat dog all right so if you have in your
household it's probably not a good match
exactly yeah so he's been there a long
time his fee waived okay and he is
neutered so he can go home today he's
ready to go he's so sweet you are a
sweet boy all right let's get Kobe a
home everybody four years old he's
neutered and he's ready to go thank you
John Andy's free may I just mention one
thing yes um kitten season is upon us
okay so we're really looking for Fosters
for kittens oh yeah and fosters for big
dogs too okay we need kittens they need
kitten Fosters you bet yeah it's
springtime thank you John good to see
you thank you Kobe let's get you a home
oh he was so so cute I was interested
until he said not a cat dog you're kind
of done well if you're interested in
adopting Kobe or you'd like to know more
about helping out with fostering kittens
or even fostering large dogs you can
call or email the animal foundation that
information is right there on your
screen and we'll have it on our website
too because we feature the segment every
week now on eightnewsnow.com and after
you pick up Kobe at the animal
foundation why not head down to
Henderson put a leash on of course
Henderson's opening a new park today
it's Dundee Jones Park does ribbon
cutting at three o'clock the park is
named after the city's first Parks and
Rec director you can find it over at
Horizon Ridge and St Rose Parkway one of
many parks in in Henderson is it